alors les cherry on va faire un petit
peu le tour des souvenirs de tpm pays
mais juste avant il y à une chroniqueuse
je vous le dis qui vit un enfer
cette chroniqueuse je vous le dis on a
dû la flouter pendant des années à
chaque fois qu'elle apparaissait sur les
extraits de touche pas à mon poste elles
étaient floutés une célèbre émission a
même fait un reportage qui n'a jamais
été diffusé on a réussi à avoir les
images de cette chroniqueuse qui vit
l'enfer regardez après une brouille avec
l'animateur cyril hanouna et l'odyssée
retrouver flouté à l'écran sur toutes
les rediffusions de l'émission tpm p un
drame dont elle a encore du mal à parler
face caméra arts au début ça me
paraissait facile
j'arrivais à vivre avec mais après dans
la vie de tous les jours c'est devenu
super compliqué quoi bonjour merci j'ai
réservé une chambre chez vous très gaz
par an plus tôt
bien sûr on est tanné si finir si
excusez moi madame c
vous reconnais pas sur la photo ah oui
pardon tenez voilà comme ça
excusez moi je
est-ce qu'à un moment vous avez quand
même pu jouir de cette notoriété depuis
mon départ de tpm p j'ai eu plein de
propositions mais pour être chroniqueuse
floutés on ne me propose que ça à quoi
en fait
ça m'intéressait pas trop quoi oui
j'aime tellement ce que vous faites vous
ai adoré dans le reportage sur un trafic
de kebab d'enquêté exclusive
le témoin anonyme elle c'est gentil mais
c'était pas moi en fait
mais vous allez même tu est de la même
eau fraîche mais c'est pas moi ça va
c'est mon petit comprise pas moi salut
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez dire à cyril
hanouna aujourd'hui peut que c'est
dommage je suis triste j'aimerais qu'on
mette un terme à tout ça j'aimerais
qu'on arrête de ce foot et entre nous et
je vais vous souhaiter à tous un très
bon anniversaire
j'ai eu un anniversaire tpm p neuf ans
déjà et cyril tu le sais bien
voilà je serai toujours ta petite beauté
tu seras toujours mon baba je vous
embrasse tous très très fort [ __ ]
j'embrasse par modelo dit tu es
formidable
je l'adoré le lieu